[Music]
you seen all that the new AR [__] I saw
I saw like The Lex Freedman episode or
just a clip from it where they were like
as they were like uh their AI like
avatars or whatever scary genius what
they create a codec instead of a video
stream because a codec is a codec like
uh I believe I don't want to butcher
this but my understanding of a codec is
it's like a wrapper
around the file so like programmatically
it like wraps the information yeah right
okay and
so instead of producing a video stream
they basically created like a codec for
your face okay and so it wraps the data
that's coming through and then it can
like map it to that code codc okay so
instead of streaming 30 frames per
second or whatever it's just like a
thing that's like reactive to your face
kind
of
uh probably explain that horribly but
play it or with sound I just want to
hear what sound and just feels like
we're in the same room this is really
the most incredible thing I've ever seen
sorry to be in your personal space it'
be so funny pause it done before it' be
so funny if Lex was like who this is
crazy it's like we're in the same room
yeah Mark's like did you just smell me
just had to able to smell
yet that's
crazy I just had to see what level of
immersion we had yeah yeah we developed
a oh man that's
crazy he lean no he doesn't even kiss he
just leans in with for the kiss yeah
yeah well man it's like we're in the
same room together
uh Lex Lex Lex what are you doing no Lex
opens his eyes and marks
like
man if you're listening on audio I was
doing Mark Zuckerberg pulling his penis
out we've actually made a codec for the
human penis as well [__] it's just
blowing him for an
hour tastes so
real dudes on Twitter like can't believe
Zuckerberg went you know in 18 months
from this it's like I saw some tweets
that were like screenshots of the first
one you know with his like stupid ass
Avatar yeah can't believe he went from
this to this in 18 months just that's
just Mark with that [__] machine with
the you know with the [__] vagina
[Laughter]
yeah the [__] wood router with the
you know Fleshlight in it are you
talking about the one that went viral
Twitter yeah the one yeah the one the
squs that was yeah that [__] is crazy up
man it's like if you got this you are
way too far gone yeah it's over man it's
over for you it's over yo you got a link
for that no relax Lucas
whoa thanks for that image Luke
yeah thanks for that mental image I'm
only going to see one thing when I shake
your hand now even that I I feel like
we've choked each other from fur
whoa we've choked each other from
further
distances distances than it feels like
we are right now I mean this awkward
left
yeah yeah you're
right hey man hey I thought this was
just going to be an interview can you
stop trying to kiss me it is sorry it's
just so immersive yeah just want to see
how immersive it can be
yeah Mark just like trying to have a
normal conversation he's just
like man it's crazy it track tracks a
tongue really
well
Lex sorry I'm just seeing how responsive
it
[Laughter]
is shit's so immersive it's
crazy yeah stupid
[__] Mark just look back somehow legs
got his [__] in there just full on
just full on just
moing just moing him Mark's like I
didn't even know he had the capability
to do
that just a full on like the Kevin like
the Kevin like the [__] the N Video
just push pushing his balls
back can you see
that can see that [__] I I didn't even
know we had I didn't who made made that
I don't even this guy his legs up yeah
showing his
ass so funny just goes blank for a
second and then just a dick comes in
from the from the
darkness
yeah oh wow the helicopter works oh that
works
wow keep playing this with no sound cuz
it actually looks pretty cool oh scary
man Lex had to like go in and scan his
face did he
yeah but I bet like talking to someone
would
feel oh yeah bro imersive Zoom meetings
are about to be something else yeah
Lauren's about to come in here and take
social photos I'm going stand up and
show my
ass just Moon the
camera episode 311 was crazy that was
crazy just one of them is yeah closeup
whoa damn 312 312 yeah 312 312
312 yeah no this is going to be crazy
when we're all living in the LA Noir
game with each other on a zoom meeting
yeah X for respect yeah Mark looks more
human here than he does in real life
yeah I like how they got the most on the
Spectrum dudes to display facial
expressions yeah yeah
exactly like looks like he's going to
[__] kill him yeah that [__] is scary
man you know what I would do with this
what I would I would uh lock it out so I
would set it to permanent eye
contact oh yeah so no blinks no nothing
yeah I'd be just in a
[Laughter]
meeting and I'd be that would be
horrifying Noel you there yep yep yep
and your head auto tracks whoever's
talking I'll be a menace with this in a
zoom meeting like doing what it's
someone just trying to explain some [__]
to I just be floating through the table
and knocking [__]
over I just be looking
possessed yeah you move really far away
just into the distance yeah I'm
listening no keep going keep
going you sure you're really far away
yeah I can hear you keep going just talk
a little louder
or I just go all like I put my avatar
all the way in the floor so just my eyes
are coming up on the floor I'm
listening I'm down here I'm down here
I'm a little
mouse I'm just thinking about the just
dude in VR the poker game yeah yeah he's
like what does he say he's like you just
got to go all
in you know you could use a few you
whatever the [__]